mobilisation ce mardi de la fonction
publique quelques 80 rassemblements de
fonctionnaires sont attendus à travers
le pays de mobilisation à l'appel de
quatre organisations syndicales
les agents de la fonction publique
estime que leurs salaires ne sont pas à
la hauteur de leur engagement
on retrouve en direct notre reporter
reste el farj et c'est bonjour vous êtes
à bercy devant le ministère de
l'économie où vous suivez pour nous
cette mobilisation quelles sont les
revendications des agents de la fonction
publique
[Musique]
et bien ce qu'il souhaite avant tout
c'est une hausse générale des
rémunérations de la fonction publique et
la vàd de ce qu'ils appellent être une
politique destructrice du service public
autrement dit doha ils demandent
l'abrogation de la loi dite de
transformation de la fonction publique
qui selon le fragilise à tout le secteur
ils demandent aussi l arête du gel du
point d'indicé ce qui servent à calculer
la rémunération à des agents de la
fonction publique ce dernier est gelé
depuis 2010 je vous propose d'écouter le
secrétaire général de la fsu qui a un
vrai sujet là je pense qui concerne
l'ensemble de la société 1
est ce qu'on a besoin de fonctionnaires
d'agents publics bien rémunérés avec une
reconnaissance du coût de leur
qualification de leur engagement au
service des autres et savait où on
allait les résultats la désinscription
dans les concours de l'enseignement
on n'a pas assez de candidats pour faire
prof par exemple on voit dans
l'hospitalière des infirmières qui s'en
vont dans le privé parce qu'elles sont
mieux payés et que dans l'hôpital public
ça devient impossible à gérer les
conditions de travail sont dégradées et
donc ça c'est vraiment un sujet de
société et il faut reconnaître
qu'aujourd'hui la fonction publique elle
est essentielle mais il faut la financer
et notamment par les salaires ben voilà
à doha pour les revendications générales
sachez qu'un autre cortège devrait se
former ici celui est des professionnels
de la santé car elle malgré le plan du
gouvernement pour l'hôpital avec
notamment une hausse des rémunérations
283 euros
le compte n'y est pas du tout pour les
organisations syndicales sur le volet
financier il souhaite que cette
augmentation soit appliquée à tous fous
les professionnels sans distinction il
souhaite aussi et c'est un point très
important
un recrutement massif car tous ceux à
qui nous avons parlé
si nous l'ont dit le secteur manque
cruellement d'être activités et puis
enfin il réclame l art est bien
évidemment est des fermetures de lits ce
cortège là devraient s'élancer aux
alentours de 13h30 direction l'hôpital
cochin estelle farges en direct de bercy
merci pour toutes ces précisions